je vais vous parler en fait ici de
partager de coopération de nouvelles
façons de faire société en ensemble et
je le fais dans une bretagne qui est une
terre de coopération la bretagne est
riche effectivement d'une tradition de
la coopération des marins pêcheurs tu de
l'agriculture des ouvriers et
aujourd'hui il s'agit pas simplement de
coopérer il s'agit aussi de développer
des pratiques collaboratives
c'est un peu ça que je vais essayer de
vous expliquer dans un monde qui est
difficile dans ce monde d'aujourd'hui
dont les principaux organisateurs
vacille on voit bien que les ressources
se raréfient et qu'on ne pourra pas pro
de la planète ne sera pas assez grande
et assez riche pour produire à tout le
monde
le mode de vie occidental on voit bien
qu'il ya des problèmes du réchauffement
climatique
on voit également toute une remise en
question des principes un peu
démocratique
on sait plus très bien où la société va
il ya toute cette transformation liés au
numérique est donc dans ce monde qui est
qui en difficulté eh bien on a un mot
pour parler de système complexe qui
traverse une crise et ce mot c'est donc
la transition
nous sommes aujourd'hui confrontés en
fait à plusieurs transitions et est donc
dans cette transition il ya la
transition numérique
bien sûr il ya la transition énergétique
la transition citoyenne mais aussi la
transition du travail parce que des
suppressions d'emploi vont aussi être
apportée par le numérique et dans un
monde de lorsque l'ancien se meurt et
que le nouveau ne parvient pas à voir le
jour dans cette arène y surgissent des
monstres comme le dit gramsci et dans la
multiplication des conflits
le repli identitaire l'absence de
repères des millions de personnes sont
en désarroi et il y avait aussi dans
toutes ces suppressions massives
d'emplois donc nous voici confrontés en
fait à une perte de sens
on sait plus quel sens partagé nous
réunit et comme le dit michel serres
cette crise d'ailleurs c'est
principalement le malaise dans l'eau
tête devant les immenses changements qui
sont à l'oeuvre
et dans ce monde en transition le non
usage des outils numériques apporte
énormément de changements nous avons un
mot pour parler de la société d'avant
l'écriture avant l'écriture c'était non
il ya 3000 ans ça s'appelle la
préhistoire mais on n'a pas encore de
mot pour parler de ce xxème siècle
pourtant si proche d'avant le numérique
et les changements qui sont à l'oeuvre
avec l'écriture avec l'imprimerie ou
avec le numérique sont du même ordre de
grandeur
simplement pour le numérique ça se fait
en dix ans attend 30 ans donc c'est
autour de cela que je vais essayer de
vous parler de nouvelles façons
effectivement de faire société
pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui les
pratiques évoluent beaucoup d'entre vous
utilisent le bon point et dans leboncoin
temps en temps vous vendez de temps en
temps vous achetez vous déplacez avec du
covoiturage ou avec airbnb pour se loger
et donc cette idée effectivement dans
lesquels chacun peut proposer des
services est tour à tour consommateurs
et acteur c'est ce qu'on appelle société
contributive et donc nous voilà
maintenant dans un temps où chacun a sa
façon peut être acteur dans cette
société et donc si l'on revient la
spirale un petit peu correspond un petit
peu à l'histoire de ce que j'ai appris
en étant élue chargée de du numérique et
d'économie sociale et de la citoyenneté
sur brest
c'est cette progression que je vais
essayer de vous décrire aujourd'hui le
premier point qui que j'ai appris c'est
l'importance dû faire avec
c'est à dire qu' on ne peut pas dans ce
système de transition décidé les choses
d'en haut on devrait pas faire des
grandes réformes qui s'applique à tout
le monde
d'un coup
et pour favoriser l'accès aux outils du
numérique quand je suis arrivé sur ma
délégation d'élus j'ai essayé de mettre
des points d'accès public à internet que
par dérision un petit peu pour s'amuser
on a appelé les papilles et c'est pas
pire que l'on a mis en place et bien et
on les a mis au rythme des gens et
aujourd'hui il y en a cent huit dans la
ville avec une très grande variété de
lieux
mais entre le premier centre social où
le premier équipement de quartier la
première bibliothèque de quartier et le
dernier avec quipements de quartier il a
fallu dix ans et donc dans cette logique
dû faire avec
il faut respecter le temps long des
évolutions et on a la même chose aussi
pour l'école c'est pas les tablettes ou
les pc dans les classes qui changeront
fondamentalement les choses
ces deux nouvelles façons d'apprendre et
ses nouvelles façons d'apprendre de
faire classe faire court de diffuser de
la connaissance de guider les élèves
eh bien il faut que les enseignants le
fassent à leur rythme d'appropriation et
donc le faire avec c'est pas quelque
chose qui est courant dans une
collectivité ou dans un ministère on a
l'habitude de décider d'en haut une
politique alors que là on est dans une
logique où on le fait sur le temps long
au rythme des gens et ce qui est
remarquable c'est de voir que en disant
il n'y avait pas un seul équipement de
quartier qui soit bibliothèque
municipale mairie quartier centre social
maison pour tous patronage laïque ou
autres qui ne soit pas papy donc donner
le temps aux gens leur permet de se
l'approprier à leur rythme et de faire
en sorte que tout le monde y viennent le
deuxième élément qui danse est un
parcours que j'ai fait c'est
l'importance d'être en attention aux
personnes c'est à dire que énormément de
perse de personnes aujourd'hui sont
prêtes à s'impliquer dans des projets et
au lieu de faire un appel à projets eh
bien on a fait ce qu'on appelle des
appels a envie bien sûr je le disais pas
comme ça vis-à-vis de la tour des
finances
ça faisait un peu bizarre
mais le principe c'est que tous les
projets sont retenus
la dernière année du été élu il y avait
43 projets 42 été retenue un seul n'a
pas n'a pas été simplement parce que
effectivement c'était un projet
personnel mais des projets c'est des
choses magnifiques comme ce que fait mme
monique dans sa classe de dispositifs
relais ou à l'accueil des collégiens qui
sont mis en échec de système scolaire
qui ont du mal à s'insérer socialement
et tout simplement les met en situation
de professeurs pour des personnes très
âgées de la résidence louise le roux
moyenne d'âge 85 ans et quand un jeune
en difficulté qui est perdue se retrouve
à être professeur et bien du coup il
reconquiert une estime de soi et il
devient fier de lui-même et a envie
d'apprendre à nouveau donc être
attention c'est considérait
effectivement que dans un territoire
beaucoup de gens ont des projets
beaucoup de gens ont des envies de faire
et que le rôle de la collectivité c'est
de savoir effectivement associé ces
personnes et les faire travailler en
réseau le troisième volet c'est le
donnait à voir donner à voir c'est un
petit peu la même chose c'est-à-dire que
tous ceux qui font des choses
eh bien il faut les publier il faut les
rendre publiques
alors c'est pas du tout dans notre
culture d'apprendre à publier
d'apprendre à écrire
et pourtant ça marche tout ce pied a été
développée l'a été à travers des sites
contributifs où tout le monde a le droit
d'écrire et sur un magazine comme attiré
bresse par exemple eh bien nous avons à
peu près une vingtaine d'articles
publiés chaque semaine nous avons 1500
visiteurs par jour 1500 abonnés et c'est
tout un chacun qui participent à un
projet qui raconte ce qu'il fait et ce
qui est important là dedans c'est que
c'est celui qui fait idy et que dès que
quelque chose est fait et bien on le
donne à voir donc tous les projets par
exemple des appels à projets sont
publiés et donc à une dynamique comme ça
de confiance qui se met en place avec
ses logiques de publier et
malheureusement ce n'est pas encore le
cas et dans la plupart des appels à
projets des ministères des collectivités
les projets restent secrets il reste
caché alors que sont des belles choses
et qu'il faudrait effectivement les
publier et apprendre aux gens en publié
et dans le rapport du sel nîmes
on essaie justement de d'insister pour
que l'école apprennent à publier dès
l'école primaire que les jeux les jeunes
aillent à la rencontre ce qui se fait
dans la ville et apprennent à dire des
choses à s'exprimer sur le web
le quatrième volet ces outillages
il est important effectivement d'aider
les gens à manipuler ces outils je ferai
pas le calcul ici mais réaliser un
atelier par semaine c'est l'équivalent
de 20% temps plein c'est pas grand chose
donc dès que quelqu'un a besoin d'être
formés ont lieu mais l'information à sa
disposition
avec un deuxième volet de formation qui
sont les formations aux méthodologies de
la coopération coopérer ça s'apprend à
l'école
vous comme moi nous avons appris à
cacher notre copie nous avons appris à
faire de la compétition alors que dans
le monde d'aujourd'hui une société
contributives
il faut apprendre à réutiliser donc à
copier quelque part il faut apprendre à
faire avec d'autres à coopérer et donc
tout ça ça demande un changement de
culture qui l'important effectivement de
mettre en place avant dernier volet
justement la coopération la coopération
s'est pas c'est pas inné et si on avait
dit il ya vingt ans que écrire tous
ensemble une encyclopédie où chacun va
le droit d'écrire ce qu'ils voudraient
ça marcherait ben non c'est aurait été
complètement illusoire et bien sûr brest
on a essayé de faire un équivalent de de
wikipédia qui s'appelle wiki brest c'est
simplement un espace où chacun peut
raconter des histoires sur son vécu sur
le patrimoine des recettes de cuisine et
par exemple aujourd'hui donc sur wiki
brest chacun des journaux de quartier à
un portail où tous les journaux sont mis
en place et donc on apprend
effectivement à monter ensemble des
projets à travers la coopération avant
dernier volet de cette spirale après
faire avec et très intense y ont donné à
voir outillés coopérer la question des
commun qu'est ce que c'est qu'un commun
et bien
on est ici tous en train d'enfer à parce
que les tedx sont mis sous une licence
qui permet en fait de rejouer la vidéo
vous pouvez la reprendre si vous trouvez
un truc intéressant vous pour la montrer
à des amis le passé dans une association
le passé dans une classe et donc ça
c'est un commun des communs maintenant
aussi il y en a beaucoup des communs
populaire qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
commun bah c'est un jardin partagé
un groupe de gens s'organisent pour
produire un jardin avec des règles
propres aux jardins et petit à petit
cette notion de commun prend de
l'importance parce que ça regroupe des
acteurs du logiciel libre des
territoires en transition
des artistes et puis tout ce monde de la
science et de la recherche et vous
verrez parce que le projet de loi sur le
numérique est mis au débat pour avant
qu'il soit voté par le parlement et donc
il est proposé par exemple que les
publications scientifiques deviennent
des communs c'est à dire que les
scientifiques qui sont payés sur de
l'argent public puisse effectivement
décidé que leur travail sera réutilisé
par tout le monde
alors qu'aujourd'hui les clauses avec
des revues comme elle et vire ou
d'autres empêche cette réutilisation et
aboutisse à ce que la science ne sont
pas accessibles à tous voilà un petit
peu tout la logique qui s'est mis en
place progressivement et qui constitue
un petit peu ce que moi j'appelle une
gouvernance contributif c'est à dire une
façon de faire dans la société dans
lequel le rôle de la collectivité des
élus n'est plus de prescrire mais
d'essayer d'être en intention de faire
avec les gens de rendre compte de ce que
font les gens de les outiller pour
qu'ils soient autonomes et donc c'est
toute une dynamique contributif comme ça
qui se met en place et dans nos sociétés
en transition eh bien il ya énormément
d'innovation sociale qui transforme la
société aujourd'hui pour répondre
justement aux enjeux des transitions
énergétiques du climat eh bien ce sont
souvent les citoyens qui à travers des
territoires en transition les
incroyables comestibles du jardin
partagé ou d'autres initiatives de
circuits courts
de recyclerie et c'est effectivement de
prendre en compte une autre culture une
autre une autre façon de faire
donc c'est cette dynamique là de la
société contributif qui aujourd'hui est
en train de se développer et de prendre
de l'importance
ce que la coopération produit c'est la
capacité des gens à travailler ensemble
on a par exemple sur brest des
bibliothécaires qui sont mis en réseau
coopératif c'est à dire un réseau
bibliothécaire qui quelles que soient
leurs employeurs que ce soit une mairie
que ce soit une université que ce soit
une association ou un centre d'urbanisme
ou la chambre de commerce
elle le sait change entre elles ce
réseau sur brest aujourd'hui regroupe
200 documentaliste résultat au lieu
d'aller se former à rennes ou paris
sur les 200 il ya toujours quelques unes
d'entre elles jeudi une passe que
majoritairement très féminin qui s'est
montré un petit peu tel outil ou qui
montrera son innovation et qui fait que
l'ensemble des personnes des
bibliothèques avancent beaucoup plus
rapidement
ensemble évolué avec leur travail et
développent des innovations sociales
donc on a toutes une transformation de
la société qui se met en place grâce
effectivement à cette dynamique du
travail en réseau là je suis en train
d'essayer un réseau pro fabre est
également des étés professeurs qui sont
aussi dans cette logique d'innovation
pour une école créative est ouverte
ce changement n'est pas simple parce que
encore une fois quand vous regardez le
fonctionnement des services publics des
grandes entreprises mais aussi de cette
association
on est encore dans un fonctionnement qui
est hiérarchique et cloisonnée alors que
là on va ex-époux c'est effectivement à
ce que les gens développent des choses
c'est ce qu'on appelle aussi tout le
travail sur le pouvoir d'agir ou en
anglais l'empowerment ou en québécois
l'an capacitation c'est-à-dire
considérer que les personnes sont
porteurs d'innovation sociale les
personnes peuvent effectivement
améliorer le service rendu
inventer de nouveaux services
et je rêve par exemple d'avoir des
espaces de coworking pour les profs
aujourd'hui où est ce que les profs de
lycée de collèges peuvent travailler
ensemble
sûrement pas dans la salle des classes
on prend le café donc pourquoi il n'y
aura pas de lieu de coworking comme il
existe ici à saint brieuc pour des
entrepreneurs du web ou autres pourquoi
il n'y aurait pas de l' espace de
coworking pour les employés de la
collectivité pour eux aussi ils
expérimentent invente de nouveaux
services parce qu en se rencontrant
plusieurs on a des idées on s'enrichit
les uns les autres
donc c'est un petit peu toute cette
dynamique un peu de la coopération que
je voulais un petit peu mettre en avant
ici est ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'à travers mon expérience personnelle
la coopération apporte un vrai plaisir
jamais en sur l'espace des dix neuf
années où j'ai été élu
je n'étais sont des situations de
conflits avec les acteurs qui partagent
cette logique
bien sûr dans la vie municipale c'est
toujours un peu compliqué mais ça c'est
l'aspect partidaire des par contre quand
on est dans une logique de d'attention
de coopération et bien les personnes le
voit très vite et à partir de là donc on
peut développer énormément d'initiatives
la difficulté aujourd'hui c'est que si
vous recherchez prendre un exemple de
l'innovation sociale dans les
délégations où j'ai tout ce dont j'avais
la responsabilité sur l'économie sociale
démocratie locale et de la citoyenneté
numérique
j'ai collecté les innovations ça faisait
60 innovation qu'on a publié dans un
magazine qui s'appelle bretagne créative
et puis si vous faites le calcul
si on va maintenant non pas sûr que ces
chants délégation mais qu'on rajoute la
jeunesse les sports et tout laisser les
questions qui sont qui sont traités dans
une ville on en aura pas 60 dans leur a
peut-être 200 300 400 et si on passe à
l'échelle de la bretagne il faut x 20
c'est à dire qu'on en aura entre cinq et
dix mille ou est-ce qu'en bretagne on
peut voir ces centaines l'innovation
autre exemple j'ai essayé aussi dans mon
travail d'appliquer ces
c'est même logique et on a collecté les
innovations pédagogiques les initiatives
des enseignants sur 150 enseignants
on en a vu 40 que l'on a publié sur un
site qui sony qui s'appelle innovations
pédagogiques dont 40 pour cent cinquante
une personne sur quatre en bretagne dans
le supérieur il doit y avoir à peu près
4000 ou 5000 enseignants du supérieur
donc on devrait avoir un millier
d'innovations dont les et on les a pas
donc aujourd'hui c'est un peu ce
plaidoyer que je voulais faire ici c'est
à dire essayer la coopération vous
verrez c'est un vrai plaisir et une fois
qu'on a fait une expérience irréversible
de coopération on ne revient pas en
arrière et publié parce qu'effectivement
comme ça d'autres utiliseront ce que
vous faites
merci